hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to corpse party no I
just got into it with the mechanics that
I'm actually getting deep into the game
and what the hell is that those tomato
vines what is going on here the green
bile here absorbs the livings energy if
you want to die feel free to roll around
in it oh well that seems like such a
cool offer I don't see a downside to
that I remember an E when I just ran
right into the dev that was fun the
twinkling lights shall illuminate your
path and become a bridge before you okay
the window won't budge is jarred shut so
what I need to do is I need to make the
twinkling lights appear so that it can
illuminate my path I'm assuming that
means I need to knock out the power in
some way I don't think there's another
way for me to go maybe I can go back and
get that wooden plank from before
because it's not gonna be useful so if I
get that I'll be able to make a bridge
over there and then be able to carry on
my way so let's try to do that real
quick before I go anywhere now once
again please be gentle with me in the
comments I am trying my best I am not
intentionally dumb I am very much
unintentionally dumb and I really want
to impress you guys with my ability all
I have is a lyrically thought voice
what's going on no way the whole place
is wrecked yeah so we're gonna pick up
the board's we're gonna take it so we
can't use the bear anymore but we will
need it later on later on meaning
immediately now come on go hey what are
you doing here go let's go come on we
got no time we got no time to waste we
got a long game to go through this game
actually is quite long if you've known
other people to play this game it can be
up to hours and hours and hours there
are some like 3040 part series on
YouTube but I'm gonna try to get through
it as expediently as possible with these
longer Let's Plays I often like to make
it not take as long because I don't want
to waste people's time when I'm playing
it alright let's see where this goes
hello Oh lovely always read the posters
in search the bookcases if you want to
leave I have been unless I've been
missing summon and then maybe I then
maybe I haven't been windows won't buzz
blood stain on the wall over there but I
don't think and get to it
okay let's go I got damnit what the hell
how was I supposed to know it was there
I took of two points outs on everybody
that's hardly fair
the green vial blah blah blah feel free
to roll it around it it if you're a
douche bag okay where does this lead
this whole place is gonna be a maze ah
two places with which to switch eyes
there's something in this bookshelf the
old key is on top of a shelf forbidden
key for the forbidden offices cool
filled a dangerous looking broken glass
um you can faintly see a yellow piece of
paper wedged among okay the lake became
deceased the Academy's conclusion our
reputation cover it up I can't read most
of these big words
neither can i parent Li and I've been in
school for a long time ex month 24th day
today's class Kives suddenly missing
what so tattered I can barely read it
thanks guys various children's drawing
the door in the cabinet a devil in white
is stabbing an angel and black
repeatedly good
why so apparently right now it's very
important to start reading as where as
was before not as important okay so Lala
be very careful gently go through the
area are those are those uh those
changer those just resetting every time
I enter a new area that's what I want to
know whoa what the what does that do
don't die I won't let you die thank you
although that sounded kind of menacing
not exactly sure what to make of that
I'm gonna save a lot if you don't know
me I am a [ __ ] saver on these steps
of things see you did I look in the
bookshelves in here was this where
another tangle there tangled hair patch
thing fell out I need to check the
individual desks I really hope not cuz
that's gonna be a lot of stuff that I
need to check use forbidden key who the
mood changed in here so what do we got
what you can see is not only the truth
you must take a leap of faith
okay so I'm assuming that means I need
to jump or find the path that's not
exactly there so that I can move forward
but where is the path how will I know
what is truly wall that was easier than
I thought it'd be so uh can I have that
can I have it
okay well I mean that that's good at all
but I can't get the thing what do you
want from me I want the thing it's right
there come on and give it to me I've
been good haven't I
I've read you're very complex clue my
big brain solved the puzzle maybe that's
not the right one I want it I want it do
I need to use an item on it Twitter use
magic
who's owed Oh use your magic use your
magic deal.we your magic you good we're
floating okay apparently I can't get
that I'm assuming I can't get that right
now so I'll get I'll approach that later
this I need to go this way for some
reason now hang on hang on again maybe
there was some other reason no no no
it's all the same why why wait I can't
go to hell
what the hell I can't go now what
happened what changed what changed
something changed I can't go now oh now
I can go wait pause it's not working
clan I don't know what you want from me
game oh oh oh oh oh oh oh I needed to go
another way okay ACK weird fought
acquired five pairs of blessed shoes
that's good that's one pair for
everybody only infects the party's
holding them please keep that in mind so
I need to somehow get other thing whoa
whoa oke okay
there we go all right good job everybody
well done besides that little moment of
panicking we did a good job staying on
head-on level-headed level-headed miss
miss miss miss is there any other
forbidden door I think those the only
ones so okay now that I got the blessed
shoes I'm assuming that means that I can
walk through the brownie stuff the
garbled e Guk plants that kill you stuff
is that what I can do I don't know if
that's what I can do oh he'll be help me
understand everybody what do I need to
do now is this gonna be good for me
because the other party doesn't have
that yet so I'm just assuming I'm gonna
take a leap of a there like before ooh
very nice
oh it almost tickles my bum bum' as I
walk through the window Mon budge it's
jammed shut well now we can keep moving
forward let us see what awaits us in the
darkness in the bloody holes of music
and dance lies a family lost their
chance
the mother Long's verse and and sanguine
child the father his bones dripping with
bile ok good poem read that on poetry
night hello it's said that one of the
holes can change in length have you
heard of this I don't know her your
spirit giving me advice or you just a
gobbledygook why would I want it to
change in length it does not need to be
adjustable for me ok
oh good the girls bathroom wait why am i
girl another user reflected on the other
side what is is main character too
polite to what your mirror reflection
isn't showing in the mirror I have a bad
feeling about this
I've had a bad feeling about this whole
game so it's clear the no one's in there
but for some reason it's locked
how do you know it's clear how is it
exactly clear are you sure it's exactly
clear ok this was a fun exercise I'm
glad we did this
Berlioz nothing here I'll worry so
that's good good good good glad that
happened let's go into boy's bathroom
that's where the good stuff
filled with a red liquid blood shouted
to pieces
something is clogging the sink so
there's a fear strange odor good good
shattered to pieces good smells of
ammonia you mean well I think you all
know what it means for those who do not
know this is the difference between the
boys in the girls bathroom oh come on
there's got to be something to that
what's going on there there's got to be
a secret that I'm not doing like the
opposite of that window what am I not
getting here what am I not getting here
why is this one in particular not
showing in the mirror can I smash it can
I hit it hard
can I smash through it I don't know let
me make another save right here just in
case I have to go back for some reason
ha I don't seem to be making much
progress over on this party so I'm gonna
try to switch over to the other one I
mean I got through and I got the blessed
show Big Brother what's up Yuka oh no no
no no no no no no we are in a ghost
school me like now can't hold it in want
me to go with her no do we be alone I'll
go no I'm worried about her I'll go oh
no I'll leave you by oh no really I
don't mind you know thank you big
brother
jeez how old are you again put him
scared no wait no you owe me come with
ya no no no we'll all go together
make it quick I'm watching okay wait
here
no bad this bad you don't need to go to
Cerrito Fuca I'll pee in one of these
destroyed floorboards yeah they're all
don't go no let's tell mommy you're
bullying what what did I do
I'm trying to help you try to help you
yeah I read that I know
bloody halls I wonder where that could
be in the bed oh no no I left her alone
no no no no this bed knows of it oh god
what did I do wrong
Oh God
you car you done yet Oh No
whatever done doo-doo-doo
let it be add things I made a bad choice
UK hello you in there
it's me you got come on say something
please
jeez you perv
jeez if you were there say something
maybe think something happened you know
but no bad Gus Gus Gus is not good
yes of course is it good
no no bad bad bad
what go run away is nao mise oh no baby
shoes so you guys Naomi can wait Oh God
come on you Gary okay
get the door am i strong enough goddamn
door who move it it what dude
huh ah why are you kicking it what the
door ever do to you what this is you
Moaning Myrtle
did you how can I make such wrong
choices
she's dead meat that girl and it will be
the most now I refuse I refuse I don't
think I will but if you'd like I won't
stop you from leaving Oh bill you ah
this is warble No please don't do
anything even die
what if you die instead of her I'll let
her go free
yes yes I'll do it if there's no other
way to save her then I'll lay down my
own life furs so please keep your end of
the bargain save her pathetic how boring
what's transparent whitewashed tripe
everyone is looking out for number one
you want me to believe you're really
such a saint pretend she wasn't there
wasn't here yes
you twisted [ __ ] that's my sister
that's a good line get out of my way you
guy God yeah take it easy
okay I got her shoe
did I get her she okay are you okay no
don't run away come back oh okay just
going to the sink Yuka now he's probably
dead down and we could have saved her
probably made the best choice anyway you
got Big Brother Where Oh Big Brother Big
Brother Big Brother hey now I said
everyone we everything would be fine
from the start didn't I you almost
drowned in blood but hey forget about
that I'm sick of this place I want to go
home
me too oh I'm sure Naomi is not doing so
good Yuka we should hurry huh I heard
Naomi scream earlier oh oh well of
course I'm gonna pillow boy that doesn't
look too good let's save in a different
spot just in case hello go see yous are
you gonna help me find a me you're alive
isn't then nice ok can you move could
you move gonna move for me you you gonna
move all there she is hey AMI
hey Naomi wake up you okay there we are
you possessed by ghosts ah Satoshi what
happened to you nothing I was suddenly
surrounded by spirits and spirits did
they do something to you no they told me
that they were just like us for sound
arrogance or will ah same old same old
boring business you wouldn't be very
interested in that they told me that a
spirit was calling people down here
random as if searching for something
something like what I don't know but I
suddenly heard a strange girl's voice
after that everything went blank
a girl's voice like Moaning Myrtle from
the bathroom was she wearing bread sorry
I can't remember what makes you say that
because she was attacked Yuka in
lavatory earlier seriously isn't that
bloody Yuka what happened
I don't want to talk about it don't
worry the Bloods nutters you are you
hurt Naomi oh it's one I got a check of
Naomi's okay you guys fine now are you
hurt anywhere near me not at all I'm
more worried about Yuka really how about
you Yuka I'm fine let's just go oh maybe
I should have checked on Yuka first mm
you seem angry I'm sorry
how's the trying to check out they owe
me wait a minute what
what's with her jeez your face is all
red well we should go back to searching
for an exit I don't know what the girl
in red wants but it had nothing to do
with us right let's get moving
yeah got it eh Oh me I wonder if
everyone's alright I don't know but I
should switch party soon I don't know if
I was supposed to oh this has been going
down up cows wandering about that high
let's continue on don't know what I'm
supposed to do but the spirits are not
willing what is this feels like you
should you see something inside a crack
in the floor sure I'll take the strange
weird thing a lever may come in handy
let's see it cool I got an iron lever
that'll come in useful handy I don't
know hello I'm walking on sunshine whoa
okay let's switch shop over save right
before save you Sammy let's go got for a
14 year old girl she does not seem 14
she seems like 9 rate all right other
party what are we gonna do now so these
are both locked and these guys don't
have the necessary tools that the other
party does I can see some stairs heading
down to the south wing nothing said that
I could use a floorboard gap so I don't
think I need anything else like that um
did I go that way wait a minute did I go
up here don't recall going up this way
ah this is new have I been here before I
don't remember if you die here the pain
of your death will continue for eternity
that's nice that's good for that I'm
glad that is telling me that that is
that way no matter how much it hurts no
matter how much you bear it no matter
how much you grab there
no escape in that pain that's good I'm
glad for that you cannot really die here
in this horrid darkness
I regret even being born okay I don't
want to read that again it was morbid
enough the first time alright anyway
there's a poster on the bookshelf find
the ten letters good poster on the
bookshelf without cooperation Escape is
impossible
hey there's a longboard on the floor
not yet I want it okay fine I'll take it
I was hoping to get to the other door
there but I guess you can go in this way
there another anatomical model oh this
looks nice well [ __ ] I didn't last long
hey isn't this our class okay oh come on
what can I go in there why not maybe I
should put the board back okay I guess
I'm not welcome there anymore so so what
about that small scrap of paper letter
number one Oh letters okay by the
basement there is an incinerator there
is so what should we do okay if someone
had dropped a small scrap of paper
letter number two on the wall next to
the poster there's a secret button next
to the poster what okay so I need to
find a wall next oh wait over here ah ah
so if I so if I lay down my board can I
lay down my board okay no not this
poster a different poster who do are
they what fresh hell is this can't go in
there keeps pooping me back let me check
this area before I switch back to the
other party I played the other party
pretty much a lot so I'm assuming that
there might be something that I'm
missing here in terms of a poster
it's your poster secret button up there
LVM Tomica model not there okay not
there not there there's something by the
anatomical model hello again yes I know
Kiki Kiki I know what that's stupid hell
pants that's stupid that's dumb
there's no way okay not happening not
having any of this nope nope nope nope
nope nope ain't happening not even
paying it a little bit attention to that
everybody wait I'm gonna fast forward a
bit okay back in the game after that
little bit of silliness is over now now
what another thing that I need to
remember is that here I think the other
party can get to this location so I'm
wondering if I swap out here they'll be
able to see each other I don't know if
that's the case but I'm gonna try it
wait a minute and then and then what
wait and then what what are you talking
about why did it do and then did it
always do and then I don't know if it
always did and then uh so not by that
wall wait a minute is there maybe the
other maybe the other people have a
poster that they need I don't know I
don't know but I think if I go up this
way that's where the if I go down this
way I don't know I don't remember where
exactly it was where the hell was it oh
I have the shoes I can go through here I
can do that I can do that thing but if I
go up here this might be the place yes
they're over there
hi hey guys Yoshiki shinozaki are you
both okay
Sarkozy Makita are you unharmed thank
god you're all okay we're fit as can be
I'm a bit scared but and covered in
blood did you guys find an exit no what
about you we didn't find anything either
come on let's get back to the search
nakusha me hmm don't get too close to me
Crete Makita does that mean what are you
trying to say
oh yeah yo cheeky I have something to
give you for me the shoes when you wear
them the green ooze no longer harms you
what you main the ooze drains humans of
their life but these shoes babe they
prevent that just put them on
sweet sweet thanks to Toshi Satoshi's
group divided the blesser shoes with
your code Yoshiki hey that's handy
knowing nothing else is since weight
nothing else is inside I didn't even
check if anything was inside why would
there be nothing else silver dangerous
looking broken glass oh wait maybe
before I pick something up
I'm already read that so I'm good to go
bye um bye II have a good one bye okay
so I'm gonna save the game here and that
means I can go through this who's being
chicken poser we'll be together until
death do us part even though we said
that I wish they were here I guess this
guy didn't originally come alone okay
I'm checking beside every poster I don't
think there's anything No okay let's go
in this room ooh this looks fun stuff
with medical books okey dokey human
anatomy organs are painted red with real
boiled good wouldn't have it any other
way
oh I got a crystal does anyone want to
get in a circle and empower our crystals
I need a good chair crystal charging
session everybody okay there's something
behind curtain number one big brother
handsome sleepy no no no are you ok
Satoshi think we should should we think
we should take a rest it's too dangerous
what are you crazy of course not it's
too dangerous here let's not come on you
can hang in there I'll try I mean why
why would I
oh maybe I'm gonna save the game in a
different spot just in case just in case
just in case I don't know what's gonna
happen
with a rest it's a terrible idea it
feels kind of chilly here feels cold in
here I don't like this one bit
let's turn back Satoshi no we press on
like idiots
not that I can get this way anyway so uh
so okay all right
is there a draft one of these windows
open she like shut it not let a draft
here okay never mind
uh can I even go back in here and we'll
they they rest again I don't know yes
this is not a good idea
wait a minute what they okay nothing bad
happened oh that just me oh oh oh oh
okay that just made their health go back
up alright okay never mind about that I
guess that's all well and good then so
why now
okay well me now that the other team has
the shoes maybe I should trade over and
give them something good I guess
and then her girls so GA give of the lab
you and iron thing oh wait this is the
same conversation they had before
where's Fitness girl god damn we are
talked about this oh come on Sarge don't
get too close to them he's my man okay
come on we're going we're out here we
got the shoes now so those won't hurt us
not that I know anything about those
goddamn I can't go in there
want to go to there fine we'll just
carry on I don't think I even recall any
place where there were green whose spots
was there I'm not going back in the room
with that anatomical model no way no how
wait a minute oh this is the wait whoa
ooh new area I thought I went here
already
ooh oh yes yes stay away from the
science lab wall now you tell me I would
like to have known that a while ago
hello pones oh the other guys found it
what the hell is that you think I know
ladies first what do you mean by that
it's really a human corpse isn't it does
it look like a dog or cat why don't you
keep dumbass commas to yourself stupid
there's something written on the floor
don't look at the poster the message was
written in human nails by the scratch
for sway in the floor ah so is that
supposed to in question is that gonna
kill me I'm so gonna look at the poster
you guys can't tell me I'm not gonna
look at the mostly because I am
definitely looking at that poster I
cannot wait delete well I'm dad so dad
what happened who knew what the hell
where's the opening well you asked me
there's gashes all over the wall with
someone trying to claw their way out so
maybe the poster yeah the answer for be
what that say okay I'll look at the
boulder you're gonna ever leave whoa
what about to the left of the poster
button oh no did I oh no did I screw up
us was a look Oh No
hello this wasn't be something to the
left of the poster
I knew this wait I knew this ah did I
screw up I look into the pollster no no
please
why won't you leave please let me out
I'll be a good boy please tell me your
secrets Oh doh
I'm dead Oh doh deadness is my name
I very dead we're still dead we're dead
we're dead son we're dead I really don't
know what to do what am I supposed to do
well let me load the game because I
think I'd done goofed there okay so
don't read the poster but look to the
button did he laugh to ride to the
poster I'm not supposed to look at the
poster I know I'm not supposed to what
am I supposed to do what the hell was
the opening why ask me if the gas is all
of those is
what what the poopy poop I'm so sorry
that's what it said before look to the
left to the side of the poster that was
supposed to be something there well okay
that just starts up the music
all right anyway what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna figure this out in the
meantime I'm on the end the episode here
I'm gonna keep playing obviously I'm
gonna keep going to anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
ah
door
all right
can I